near the face of New Jersey did he did
you kind of give you we how did you feel
about Jersey Shore I felt like it gave
you guys like a little bit of a black
guy right I mean it's like Jeffrey
Dahmer and Milwaukee yeah yeah it did a
little bit but I mean everyone's like
are people really like that I'm like
yeah people really like are they really
I just thought they were like characters
no I mean listen they were eccentric of
like the height the height of it but
there's definitely some I know some
people like that really New Jersey yeah
especially the club heads you know
[ __ ] Meatheads you know Meatheads
Molly yeah
yeah jewels and [ __ ] it looked fun
though yeah it was good times good times
the seaside yeah but you never went that
route no no no no no no no yeah I was in
the gym too much yeah no address like
that yeah but hey it brought it brought
a lot you know I have a lot of friends
and family that own businesses over the
bridge and it brought a bunch of
business to that I didn't think about
like like the tourism I bet yeah